pour la c1 chaleureux sent bien dans ses
pattes ce chaleureux c'est guigoz six
ans avec l'absence de ses maîtres sa
nounou lui s'il s'occupe de lui
30 minutes par jour de 4 sitting la
spécialité de l'entreprise cha cha et
lulu il a toujours ce petit moment très
câlin
quand j'arrive et comme il est très
joueur encore il a besoin de dire bon là
c'est bon les cas non ça suffit on y va
on joue différents jouets pour divertir
le chat des caresses pour le détendre
quatre sites heures c'est aussi
s'assurer de la bonne alimentation et du
nettoyage de la litière tout en
stimulant l'animal pendant toute la
séance
la clé c'est vraiment l'observation il
faut savoir lire le chat faut savoir le
comprendre observer ces mouvements
observés ces signaux d'apaisement
voilà c'est important aussi d'utiliser
nous mêmes les signaux d'apaisement donc
son la communication du chat pour bien
interagir avec lui le rassure et
l'apaisé lui montrer qu'on est là pour
lui qui guide aussi un chat qui aime
bien faire de la grs donc voila merci
rugby qui veut faire des pirouettes
sauté dessus
on va essayer avec sa collègue charlotte
lucile père joe a créé sa société en
début d'année 2020 objectif proposer un
soutien quotidien aux propriétaires de
chiens et de chats des compétences
qu'elles ont acquises dans leurs
expériences précédentes en refuge et à
la spa
on a la même vision du bien-être animal
et on a eu envie de de poursuivre cette
quête du bonheur animal ensemble en
en créant cette société et on a une
manière à nous de participer à la lutte
contre l'abandon un peu
voilà notre la continuité de notre
travail à la spa a démenti car durant
cette période estivale lui s'il vaut en
moyenne dix chats par jour chez leurs
propriétaires durant l'été en france
près de soixante mille animaux sont
abandonnés selon les chiffres de la
fondation 30 millions d'amis